hello everyone so this is me shupanta
day
a student of genetic engineering and
biotechnology
at the university of thakur i have
currently been in a research fellowship
program
in omixlogic bioinformatics dr harpit
karpmadam has been my supervisor
so today i am going to show you the
project we have been working on
the research question is how the third
dose of malaria rdsa cso1 vaccine is
associated with controlled inflammation
and increased protection for this we did
bioinformatic analysis on significant
gene expression
on various stages of the vaccination
also we established a relationship
between the genes and connected them
with various pathways they affect in
2019 there are 229 million malaria cases
and among them 409 000 states occurred
there is a continuous problem with
malaria and only vaccine can help us if
we think about the long-term
solution africa is the worst sufferer
from malaria
if you look at the figure at the right
side the dark green areas in africa has
faced
10 to 40 million million cases in 2015.
other regions not much less either
and in the other figure red regions
indicate
increase in malaria cases green regions
mean
a decrease in the number of cases and
yellow means somewhat
both so i guess you all understand why
malaria vaccine must be very significant
malaria vaccine development entered a
new milestone in 2015
as rtss became the very first human
anti-parasite vaccine to pass regulatory
examination
that is our malaria vaccine it has
significantly showed that it can prevent
malaria
now you must be thinking about two
things one how does this vaccine can
protect us from malaria
and secondly why are we mainly focusing
on the thyroid dose
i will answer them both this vaccine
facilitates several gene expression
which is associated with protection
also it reduces the pathogenicity of
malaria
this is how it helps in protection and
we analyze first and second those data
sets too
but the main reason we are focusing on
the third because it is the crucial one
associated with gene expression changes
also literature
study pointed out hard vaccination
increases the protection established
significantly
on top of that our study also focused on
both regulatory vaccination and
delayed fractional third vaccination so
it was a better approach to focus
on how these dots affects gene
expression
mostly cytokine ones
here we are going to talk about the
method we followed we divided genes into
groups
so that we can do differential gene
expression factor regression
and we say plot an h clust for
visualization purpose
we found out the genes which are
significantly expressed
then we found out the up and down
regulated ones
which helped us to reach to a conclusion
with our
study with the help of literature so let
us
uh look at the data set and the groups
as you can see the organism was homo
sapiens
and ernestic analysis was done also the
sample source was
pvmc samples if you look at the groups
you will see from pre-vaccination state
to day of challenge or
control human malaria infection day
there are total six
groups and the number of samples is
275. we also analyze data sets of first
and second dose
and we'll discuss them later on
this plot includes all the samples and
what does it actually show us
it shows the variation in expression of
sample groups
we understand from this plot that day
three and day one as you can see day
three and day one
uh they are together from other groups
but not so much different from each
other
day 14 demands total in a different
cluster here
most interestingly day of challenge is
not here the day of challenge
that is not far away than day of
vaccination
day of challenge and day of vaccination
as you can see one reason of that might
be over
expression or over cytokine expression
is related with negative impact or
pathogenicity in case of malaria
so not a not an extreme response on the
day of challenge
that might be good
figures will show you how the sample
expression pattern of all the groups
changes when we compare between one
group to another group
this is necessary to understand several
gene expression is
associated with protection and various
number of significant
genes in different groups could tell us
more
about a correlation moving on at this
point we showed graphs and plots that
help us
in understanding variation in sample
expression pattern
in this slide however you can find out
219 genes are significantly expressed as
you can see 290 engines
are significantly expressed while we
compared between pre-vaccination and day
of challenge samples
in third dose here you can see the
volcano plot for all the genes and here
is
a heat map for the top 50 up and down
regulated genes
and now these figures clearly show you a
distinction
the threshold was uh fdr less than 0.005
p
value less than 0.05 as you can see it
is mentioned here
and log fc follows uh less than minus 1
or greater than plus 1.
now why is this an important
step for our analysis well now that we
found significant genes
in different samples we can see how they
are associated with different pathways
and protection in our body
let us focus on the interpretation of
what is shown till now and an analysis
of the significant genes
here we did various ontology and patho
analysis in nbc
the most interesting findings from this
was cytokine activity
their receptor interaction and
inflammatory responses
in all of the pathways or biological
molecular function
also literacy studies have found in
plasmodium
falciparum malaria in sufficient oxygen
reaching vital organs and excess release
of
pro-inflammatory cytokines might be
associated with
primary driving force of disease and
death
cytokine is associated with protection
as well as imbalanced and over
production can lead to pathogenicity
malaria related anemia
less supply of oxygen to mitochondria
also happens because of over expression
of cytokines
so how the vaccine protects us from this
double last
sort we'll get to the answers
cytogram genes are mostly down regulated
but as you can see here
the upregulated genes are mostly
associated with regulation of calcium
ion dependent exocytosis
or voltage-gated calcium channels now
moving on we can see
here the genes associated with cytokinin
inflammation
present in all three doses well
as you can see in the first dose the
expression
is upregulated on the day of vaccination
in the second dose it is both up and
down regulated as you can see up
regulation and down regulation
but in case of charge regulation the
expression
just falls here you can see it is mostly
down regulated
this is applicable for all the cytokine
related
important or significant genes moving on
we will show you a
heat map of the same here you can also
see how the expression pattern varies
from one group to another and
this also shows you a clear distinction
now we saw down regulation of cytokine
associated genes after the third dose
so we feel the need for analyzing what
happens after the first and second dose
that's what we showed you in the before
slides
we found cytokine and inflammation genes
are upregulated after the first
both up and down regulated after the
second what do you gather from this
well antibodies are produced against the
antigen
of vaccine as they are triggered from
memory especially after the later doses
also cell mediated cytokines are less
expressed
which was not the case after the first
or second dose
this is one more reason why third
vaccination is so crucial
as cytokine over expression is sometimes
called the driving force of malaria
related death
here the characterization of cytokine or
chemokine patterns produced upon
vaccination
can even contribute to the
identification of biomarkers of hexane
response
our literature study also supported our
claims and provided us with an even
broad view on genes associated with
cytokine regulation in malaria infection
cxl 9 10 11 infp1
interleukin 12b or interleukin 6 or 10
or found to be expressed significantly
in several cases of malaria
and might have other drugs related to
pathogenicity too
we also found the upregulated genes are
associated with
malaria infection now we'll move to the
next slide to summarize
what we have learned so far three doses
of malaria vaccination results in pro
and anti-inflammatory cytokines
being expressed in a balanced way and we
have noticed that after the third
third dose cytokine expression was down
regulated now it is crucial because we
have
found cytokine over expression in case
of malaria infection is associated with
malaria related death and it is mostly
associated with
pathogenicity so when this happens
it results in increased protection and
decreased negative effect of cytokine
over expression
and it all contributes to success of
malaria vaccine also we want to mention
r21 vaccine as it is showing better
result but it
still has a long way to go because the
study took place in a smaller region and
more study has to be done
now you can see all the references we
needed for this presentation
so we have come to the end thank
everyone for listening
and trying to understand how malaria
vaccination
helps in protection by influencing gene
expression
thank you again